pues es verdad es un momento histórico
para alemania de canciones
y repite donde están que este ataque a
ucrania no puede ser justificado de
ninguna manera también repite con
destaques indignante el hecho de que
rusia tenga todavía el derecho a veto
unas naciones unidas y que no otra
respuesta posible para demandar al
ataque de putin que el envío de armas a
un área y a
también ha dicho que tenemos que dejar a
putin de esta trayectoria
de guerra repite que las sanciones
económicas
son impresionantes para alemania y para
toda la unión europea y alcanzar más o
no la necesidad de optimizar su ejército
a verse una mejor a este tipo de
situaciones en el futuro y finalmente
finalmente sucede a aumentar el
presupuesto de defensa de un 2 por
ciento de este producto bruto interno y
esto esto era un pedido de larga data
del parte de la otan